hello and welcome everyone to my talks
i'm bhaskar wright shaw three and i
would be speaking on the existence of
competitive equilibrium with chores this
is joint work with jugal kirk peter
mclaughlin and ruta mehta all from
university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
okay so the talk would be concerned
regarding allocations in the exchange
model so the exchange model is a
fundamental economic model that is built
on the bader system
where a set of agents exchange a set of
items among themselves fairly and
efficiently so this involves like agents
maximizing their utility while
exchanging goods and minimizing their
disutility while exchanging bads or
chores
and i would make the settings more
formal and explicit as the talk
progresses
so first let me start with the exchange
setting with goods also commonly known
as exchange markets which is a concept
that's been there since the 19th century
from the time of leon walrus
and here we have a set of agents and a
set of divisible goods so these
divisible goods means that they can be
fractional located and each agent comes
to their comes to the market owning a
set of goods and each agent as i said
before at the high level picture is that
these set of agents want to exchange
their goods with the other agents and
maximize their utility
so let me make it a little bit more
formal so given set of agents instead of
divisible goods our goal is to find the
so-called competitive equilibrium
so by that i mean that we need to find
prices for the goods
such that each agent
sells her set of goods that she owns
earn some amount of money and then uses
this money
to buy a set of chores that maximize our
utility okay
but this activity that is like earning
money by selling the goods and then
using that to maximize our utility can
be done at any price vector what's so
special about a competitive equilibrium
vector is that while each agent does
this activity while each agent maximizes
her own utility in this process all the
goods are sold so basically demand
equals supply as a result of which these
are also called market clearing prices
okay so as they are defined right now in
this slide it's not very clear that such
prices always exist no matter how many
agents goods and what kind of utility
functions the agents have
and here i would like to mention one of
the most seminal results in mathematical
economics uh thanks to aerodibru and
also independently by lionel mckenzie
who probe the existence of competitive
equilibrium under certain mild
assumptions so these mild assumptions
will also become explicit as the top
progresses but just to mention that such
prices and allocations do exist in a
very generic setting
but most of this talk would not be on
the exchange markets and exchange market
with goods because most of the
existential and computational questions
here have been answered
so what we would be focusing on is the
exchange setting with chores which has
been relatively understudied
so
in the exchange setting with chores
again there are set of agents who come
with owning a set of chores to be done
and they exchange it with each other so
as to minimize their disputability for
instance a set of university students
teaching each other courses in order to
minimize the time and effort required
for learning
at a large scale for instance
time banks are such reciprocal service
exchange platforms that can that do
implement this so in a time bank so time
back is essentially formed by a set of
individuals from a community so each
individual offers services to other
individuals in the community and in the
process earns due time credits
then the individual uses these time
credits in order to get services from
other agents in the community
so this is this uh so the whole idea of
time credits can be more formalized and
can be made much more efficient through
the notion of competitive equilibrium
and that can be seen as an application
of most of the results that i would be
presenting at this time
so let me formalize now the setting the
exchange setting with chores so we have
a set of agents we have a set of
divisible chores and each agent has some
initial endowment of chores captured by
the endowment matrix w-i-w
the igt entry of this matrix signifies
how much amount of george j is owned by
agent i
and then as i said each agent have their
own disutility function signifying the
cost or the pain incurred by the agent
when they're allocated a particular
bundle of chores
so since we are dealing with divisible
chores an allocation can be represented
as an mda or a bundle a chore set to an
agent can be represented as an
m-dimensional vector where the jth
component represents how much amount of
chore j is being allocated
and once you feed this vector to the
disk utility function it outputs a value
which signifies that this utility or the
pain incurred
throughout the talk we make a stronger
assumption that this utility functions
that is of linearity
so if i give you an allocation if i give
you a chore set so let's say y1 y2 up to
ym the disutility encode can be read and
written as summation of d i j y j
where each d i j indicates the
disutility incurred by agent j per unit
of chore j
and as you can see the set of
permissible values for dij we do permit
an infinity value so what this signifies
is that agent i cannot be allocated the
chore j as agent i does not have the
required set of skills to do the chore
so basically it says that so d i g
equals infinity means that this chore j
cannot be allocated to agent
anyway so we have agents we have chores
and endowments and dis utility functions
and our goal is to find a competitive
equilibrium so now i would extend the
concept of a competitive equilibrium
from the good setting
so through a small example so let's say
if we have say a set of two agents a1
and a2 set up two chores c1 and c2 agent
once owns on the it show all of your two
that is c2 and a2 owns all of c1
and the disutley t is captured by the
matrix on the left hand side
if you look at it closely
i mean it's clear what should be done in
this exchange setting agent wants an
agent to have very high disunity for the
chores they own but less justice utility
for each other's chores so a natural
thing to do is to just exchange the
chores in order to minimize the
disulfide now i'd show you exactly this
happening through the notion of a
competitive equilibrium
okay so extending this concept of
equilibrium from goods the goal is to
determine prices and p and allocation x
so
at this prices each agent earns money
which is equal to the total price of the
chores that she owns
and she earns this money by minimizing
her disutility so let me make this clear
in this example so as i said agent one
here owns all of chore 2. so at a given
price vector p1 and p2 say the price of
chore 2 is p2 then agent 1
needs to earn p2 dollars of money
such that she can get this chore done
she can she she can you know you can
think of it as the time credits so if
she agent one needs to earn p2 dollars
of time credits in order to get the
chore that she has done and how will she
earn this p2 dollars of money she will
earn it by doing a set of chores that
she's comfortable with or in other ways
she earns this money fp2 by doing the
set of chores that minimizes her
disutility at this prices so as i said
so each agent i earns their endowment
money just submission of j w i j p j
by doing the set of chores that minimize
their disutility
but as said in the goods case this i
mean each agent can have this optimal
bundle of chores defined at any prices
but what's so special about the
competitive equilibrium prices is while
each agent
consumes only their optimal chores
in this process all the chores are
allocated to demand equal supply
so in this in this example that we have
so one such price could be say one
dollar of money each for chore one and
two or two
so agent one earns one dollar of money
by doing chore one entirely
an agent two owns one dollar of money by
doing chore two entirely so in a way
what essentially is happening is that
the agents are exchanging their chores
but i've explained it through the
concept of a competitive equilibrium and
this is the concept this is the most
efficient way to exchange chores when
there are more number of agents and more
number of chores with with very
complicated uh disu dispute
heterogeneous utility functions
okay so now that we have explained the
concept of a competitive equilibrium
like in the goods case the first
question is that does a competitive
equilibrium always exist and as i said
that i would promise you what these mild
assumptions are under which the
competitive equilibrium exists in the
goods case we'll see that similar
assumptions are required in the chore
setting as well
so in general a competitive equilibrium
may not exist
a very simple example being the
following where we have three sets of
agents one two and three so agents one
and two bring half units of chore one
and short two each and agent three
brings one unit of two three and the
problem here is that agents one and two
are only interested in chore one
while agent three is interested in
chords two and three so if you think
about it
like at any competitive equilibrium
agents one and two let's say p1 p2 p3
are the prices of c1 c2 and c3 at any
competitive equilibrium agents one and
two
need to earn p1 plus p2 dollars of money
together
only from c1
right so they need to earn p1 plus p2
dollars of money by doing chore c1 which
can only give them the maximum payment
of p1
so as a result of which it implies that
the price of chore 2 should be zero and
if the price of chore 2 is 0 then agent
3 will not do shorter because it is not
i mean it cannot be a part of the
optimum bundle of the age of agent 3
because he will not earn any amount of
money by doing chore 2. he will only
incur this utility so it doesn't make
any sense for him to do chore too as a
result of which or two will remain
unallocated and undone and therefore
competitive equilibrium will not exist
so the primary problem here if you think
about it is that if you have any set of
agents who are only interested in a
strict subset of chores they own then
you can never find a competitive
equilibrium right because they i mean
these agents cannot exchange because
they are only interested in a strict
subset of shorts that they are
interested in so there is no room for
exchange here
okay
so then this is naturally the first
condition that we would like to propose
that in an instance there exists no
subset of agents that can only do a
strict subset of chores that they own
and in fact this is a necessary and
sufficient condition for existence of
competitive equilibrium in the exchange
setting with goods when agents have
quasi-concave utilities
also note that this is this condition is
polynomial time verifiable
now the natural question to ask is that
is this a necessary and sufficient
condition in the exchange settings with
chores as well and unfortunately the
answer is no
so let me explain it through a small
example so consider this setting where
you have again two agents and two chores
and both agents one and two own half
units of c1 and c2 each so you can see
that this satisfy is the condition one
because each agent has i mean owns some
part of every chore
so that you cannot find a set of agents
who are only interested in a strict
subset of shorts that they own
however this instance will not admit a
competitive equilibrium so let me make
it clear why so let's say that like we
want to find prices p1 and p2 and then
eight both the agents need to earn p1
plus p2 divided by two dollars of money
by doing chores that minimize their disk
utility so first of all observe that
agent one will earn p1 plus p2 divided
by two dollars of money only from chore
one because this is the only chore that
he's capable of doing
and this would imply that the prices of
these two chores are the same p1 equals
p2
however if p1 equals p2
then agent 2 will not do chore 2 because
both these shorts have the same price
while the disutility per unit of shore
is is less for p1
in fact agent 2 will only do chore 2 if
the price of chore two is at least two
times the price of chore one as a result
of which short two will remain
unallocated undone and competitive
equilibrium therefore will not exist
here
so even though it satisfies uh condition
one
so then we ask well are there any
polynomial time verifiable necessary and
sufficient conditions to check the
existence of competitive equilibrium may
not be similar to the goods case but
something else and unfortunately not
this is the first main result of our
paper where we showed that checking the
existence of competitive equilibrium in
the exchange setting with charges np
hard so therefore the best thing that we
can hope for is polynomial time
verifiable sufficient conditions which
are simple natural and capture
interesting instances
so first i would try to address these
sufficient conditions and then we would
try to settle the existence of
competitive equilibria under these
sufficient conditions for the rest of
the time
okay
so let's look back at the example that
we had which rendered competitive
equilibrium not to exist so i claim that
the problematic edges are the edges from
a1 to c2 or a2 to c1
because if you look at it carefully both
these edges are present then a
competitive equilibrium exists if none
of these edges are present even then a
competitive equilibrium exists it's only
in the case when one of these edges
exists
that the existence of competitive
equilibrium depends on the disutility
values so this i mean so this thing can
be generalized so essentially what i'm
trying to say is think of the situation
where the disutility graph of our
instance is a disjoint union of
biclinics where the diseuletic graph is
a bipartite graph with the set of agents
in the set of chores and there is an
edge from an agent to a chore if this
chore is a finite disulpity towards this
agent so if our distributive graph is a
set of is a disjoint union of biclicks
in that case can we say something about
the existence
and it turns out that we indeed can
and this is the second main result of
our paper where we show that yes indeed
in these settings competitive
equilibrium exists
i mean on instances that satisfy both
conditions one and two while condition
two might seem to be restrictive it is
necessary because we show that if you if
that if the disunity graph is even just
one edge away from being a disjoint
union of bike leaks meaning that if it
has even one component i mean which is
just i mean which just is which is just
one edge away from being a bike click
even that case a competitive equilibrium
may not exist
so it is i mean it's quite unavoidable
unless you want to formulate conditions
which exactly depend on the disutility
values
okay so that's why i mean that's why we
want to keep things simple so we we want
something to be dependent only on the
digital 3d graph and not on the exact
distributive values the latter can be an
interesting question but that would be
for future research
okay
so
now the question is that how do we prove
the existence of competitive equilibrium
on instances that satisfy conditions one
and two and that would what and that
would be what i would be doing the rest
of the talk
so to this end i would first introduce
some preliminaries that we would require
these are the fixed point theorems
because these are also essential these
were essentially the tools that were
used to show the existence of
competitive equilibrium even in the good
setting the most basic and the
fundamental fixed point theorem being
that of the braver's fixed point theorem
which says that any continuous function
which maps a convex and compact subspace
of a euclidean space to itself will
admit a fixed point i mean i guess most
of us are familiar with this fixed point
theorem
so i would move to the next one which is
a generalization of the bravo's fixed
point theorem for
correspondences or set valued functions
so
for a correspondence where basically one
element in the set s could be mapped to
several elements in the set s
we can have a fixed point if the
following conditions are satisfied so if
the set s like before is convex and
compact
if the set of phi fs is not empty convex
and compact the set of values that s can
be mapped to by the correspondence is
non-empty convex and compact
and phi has a closed graph so close
graph is essentially uh i mean
uh generalizing the notion of continuity
to correspondences it's like upper upper
hemi continuous functions so i will not
be i mean i will not be saying the
details of what i mean continuity is i
mean just this much information would
suffice for the rest of the talk so if
you have a correspondence which
satisfies these three conditions then it
would admit a fixed point meaning that
there exists a point s such that s is
contained in phi of this so this is
called kakutani's fixed point theorem
and that's all that we need to know
so
first i would show you the proof of
existence
for the goods case
and then we would see what are the
challenges that we face when we try to
extend this proof of existence and how
we overcome these challenges
so
at a high level
for the proof of the goods case a
correspondence is defined on the domain
of prices and allocations
and then we showed that any fixed point
of this correspondence will correspond
to a competitive equilibrium and then we
show that this correspondence satisfies
the conditions in kakutani's fixed point
theorem thereby it would admit a fixed
point which would then imply the
existence of a competitive equilibrium
so just make this point a little bit
more uh clear with the slides so our
domain of prices it's a simplex domain
of prices so each each price is another
so each good has a non-negative price
and the sum of prices of the goods
equals one so this is our domain of
prices
our allocation is this domain is a space
of bounded allocations where each x i j
indicates amount of good g that can be
allocated to agent i this is not this
variable x ig is non-negative and it is
upper bounded by a finite sufficiently
large scale or m
so p and x are our domain of price and
domain of allocations respectively and
our correspondence is is defined on the
cartesian product of p and x
so now let me define this correspondence
so given a price p and an allocation x
the five p axis contains all p prime x
prime such that the following conditions
are satisfied the first thing is that if
you look at allocation x prime and if
you look at
x prime i
which is like x prime i 1 x prime i 2 up
to x prime im basically the bundle that
is allocated to agent i
it is the optimum bundle for this agent
at the price p
okay so
in so in x so in x prime yeah x prime is
the optimum bundle for for each agent i
at the price p
and then to tell you how the prices are
modified so i need to define this notion
of an excess demand
so given the allocation x you look at
the total consumption of a particular
good j so which is captured by summation
of x i j over all i and then you look at
the excess consumption so if any
particular good is consumed extra then
we say that this is a good in demand
okay so rj captures the excess demand or
in a way the excess consumption of the
good
uh under the allocation x
and what what the what the the way the
fixed point theorem wave the
correspondent modifies the prices is
extremely natural so it
looks at the goods which are in demand
and it increases their prices so each
pga first we increase it by pj plus rj
and then we renormalize it such that the
p pro such that the vector p prime
belongs to the simplex again
okay so this is exactly how the
correspondence is defined
and now let me quickly tell you why a
fixed point of this correspondence will
give you a competitive equilibrium
so first of all observe that any at any
fixed point so let's say p comma x is
contained in phi of p comma x
then
every h so if you look at every x i so
every x i is the optimal is the optimum
bundle for agent i at the price is p so
every agent is allocated their optimal
bundle of chores
okay so it suffices to show that all the
shorts are allocated so this is the only
thing that i need to show
so assume that they assume that there is
some sort and this is the crucial part
of the proof so assume that there is
some short j which is over allocated a
symmetric argument would follow for the
case when there is a chord which is
underrelocated so assume that there
exists a j where summation x i j is
strictly larger than one
then we can show that there exists a
good j prime which is under allocated
where summation x i j prime is strictly
less than one and this follows from the
fact that the total money of the agents
equals to the total price of the goods i
mean if you if you work around this then
you can you can show this kind of a rule
you can show the following
implication
and this would imply that if you look at
p prime j divided by p prime j prime
it's essentially p j plus r j divided by
p j prime plus r j prime but the fact
here is that r j is strictly positive
because chord j is over consumed and r j
prime is zero because short j prime is
under consumed as a result of which this
is strictly larger than p j divided by p
g prime which is a contradiction because
we're considering a fixed point we
should have p prime equals p
so therefore uh
at a fixed point we should have
summation x i j equals one for all the
chores
so fixed point would correspond to a
competitive equilibrium and then it is
not that hard to show that the
correspondence defined satisfies the
properties that we showed in kakutani's
fixed point theorem and thereby using
kakutani's fixed point theorem there
exists a fixed point which then implies
the existence of a competitive
equilibrium in the exchange setting with
clips
okay so this was more or less to give
you an idea of how to show the existence
of how the existence of competitive
equilibrium was shown in the good
setting
and now we try to generalize this
approach for the chores and i will tell
you the crucial difficulty that we would
encounter so like earlier we
like we define fi i mean we the domain
of prices and the domain of our
locations remain the same and we try to
define phi fp comma x to be all p prime
x prime such that
each agent gets their optimum bundle in
x prime i mean each extra x x prime i is
the optimum bundle of agent i at prices
b
and then similar to the excess demand
for goods you define the excess supply
for the chore so for each chore j you
look at the amount of chore j that is
still
i'll be still left undone
namely you look at one minus summation
of x i j so summation of x i j uh
overall i for a chord j shows how much
amount of this chord has been completed
and you look at one minus this is how
much amount of this chore still lifts to
be done so you look at the excess supply
or the amount of short j that is left
undone
and then you do something intuitive you
increase the prices of the chores that
are still left undone because yeah if
you increase the prices these shorts
will become more attractive and other
agents will be interested to do these
chores
so
p prime jst find fast pg plus rga then
you again re-normalize very similar to
the defining the correspondence for the
goods case
however
the main problem here is
in the definition of this optimum bundle
set
so this optimum bundle set would be
empty for certain prices
or certain feasible prices for instance
consider this simple instance
where there are two agents a1 and a2 a1
owns c2 completely and a2 owns c1
completely
and a1 is only interested in chore1 and
a2 is only interested in chore2 by
interested i mean they can only do these
chores
and consider this price vector where c
one has price zero and c two has price
one note that is a feasible price vector
and
here i would say that the optimum demand
bundle for a1 is empty why because in
any optimum demand bundle a1 needs to
earn one dollar of money
by doing some amount of c1 right
because it's the only chore that he's
capable of doing
and it's not possible to earn any money
by doing any amount of c1 because c1 has
price zero
so as a result of which the optimum
demand set for
agent one
under these prices is empty
so this is the problem when you try to
generalize the approach for the goods
and to circumvent this issue
we change the domain of crisis the
problem is that we should not allow such
prices
i mean we and for that we enforce one
more condition so now we have all the
prices that belong to the simplex but
with one more linear constraint which
says that you look at every component of
your disk utility graph recall that we
are working under the assumption that
our disulfidity graph is a disjoint
union of by click so you look at every
by click here and here i i enforce that
the total
uh the the total um
endowment cost of the agents or the sum
of prices of the chores owned by the
agents in this component equals the sum
of prices of the chores in the component
i mean you can you can verify here that
such a price vector here will not fall
into this new domain
that i have defined here so this is our
fix
and here for instance if let's say the
price of all the chores that an agent is
interested in is zero
then the budget of the then the sum of
prices the choice that this agent owns
will also be zero so as a result of
which this agent needs to earn zero
amount of money by doing some set of
chores and therefore not doing any
chores
is a feasible allocation so the optimum
bundle is still well defined this is how
we circumvent this issue of infi or of b
of empty optimal bundles
okay
so now let me rephrase what what we need
to find so now the problem is that since
we have made our price domain more
involved we need a correspondence which
satisfies similar properties to what was
before but it should map from this more
involved price domain to the price
domain so this is this is the main
technical uh
challenge that we still need to resolve
so in particular we want so like let's
say p prime x prime belongs to phi of p
comma x so we want as usual x prime i to
belong to the optimum bundle set of
agent i at prices p
and then
we want p prime to belong to p
and for each component of the disutility
graph we need something like p prime j
divided by p prime j prime equals p j
plus r j divided by p j prime plus r j
prime because using this similar to the
goods case we can argue about that argue
that any fixed point of the
correspondence will correspond to a
competitive equilibrium so we need such
a property
but the thing is we need such a property
and we also need p prime to belong to
the the new price domain and also we
need that phi of p comma x is non-empty
convex and compact so that we can apply
kakutani's fixed point theorem so we
need all these three properties and that
is what we show
uh that we show that yes indeed there
exists a price vector which belongs to p
and which which satisfies these
properties and the set of such price
vectors is indeed non-empty convex and
compact
uh we show this and we prove the
existence of such price vectors using
browse fixed point theorem
or in other words we use brahmos fixed
point theorem to show that there exists
correspondences that satisfy the set of
properties
and then we use the kakutani's fixed
point theorem on such correspondence to
show the existence of competitive
equilibria so in a way we are using a
nested fixed point theorem to show the
existence of competitive equilibrium in
the exchange setting with chores
okay so that is more or less i mean
there are still some challenges that you
face while proving uh continuity uh with
this more involved price domain and
everything but for the details i would
refer you to the paper but i just wanted
to highlight the main takeaways from our
paper and for the purpose of this talk
yeah um and
with that i would like to summarize so
to summarize we initiated the study of
competitive equilibrium in the exchange
model with chores
and we saw that it behaves differently
uh from the competitive equilibrium in
the exchange setting with goods like to
start off it's np hard to check the
existence of competitive equilibrium as
opposed to the existence of a polynomial
time verifiable necessary and sufficient
conditions in the good setting
and then we showed that the competitive
equilibrium exists in instances which
satisfies say two conditions which are
simple conditions namely no subset of
agents can only do a strict subset of
chores they own and the disunity graph
of the instance is a disjoint union of
biclinics
and as for future directions i guess the
first question that follows is since we
have established the existence of
competitive equilibrium using fixed
point theorems the question is do we
really need fixed point theorems to show
existence so like uh so that that's the
first first question that we would like
to ask that what is the complexity of
finding competitive equilibrium under
these sufficient conditions so maybe it
is ppadi hard or does there exist a
polynomial time algorithm then which
would show a more elegant proof of
existence
so
apart from that i guess we also would
like to see what is the can we show ppad
membership of finding competitive
equilibrium under sufficient conditions
because all evidences of using fixed
point theorems and also we can argue
about rationality of the competitive
equilibrium all the evidences show that
yes probably this problem at least is in
ppad so can we come up with fixed point
formulations with which we can show ppid
membership
of this problem
and then as i said earlier to
investigate the existence and
i mean existential and computational
questions of finding competitive
equilibrium in the exchange settings
under other interesting sufficient
conditions for instance at least as far
as the computation goes i guess another
interesting thing to look at is when
uh
when all agents have uh say say when
when there are no infinite
disputabilities say for instance when
all chores when all between any agent
and chore the disutility is finite in
such a case it's it's easy to show
existence but then i mean does the
problem get easier maybe can we show can
we show a polynomial time algorithm
there or even is that ppd hard i mean
all of these are interesting questions
so with that i guess i would like to
conclude my talk and thank you for
listening